es ist die größte mond mission seit 50
jahren die raumsonde channel 5 hatte in
einer bislang unerforschten regionen des
mondes zwei kilogramm gestein
eingesammelt und soll diese noch im
dezember zur erde bringen diese mission
wird als letzter unbemannter schritt zur
vorbereitung auf die mondlandung von
chinesischen taikonauten gesehen steht
chinas großen ziel den bau einer
internationalen mond forschungsstation
somit nichts mehr im wege
alle wichtigen infos dazu bekommt ja
jetzt bei klicks und salz im future geht
es dreimal pro woche spannende science
videos abonniert den kanal und aktiviert
die glocke nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen und
vielen dank für diesen coolen dem
vorschlag den petra uns über unsere
klicks um science and future telegramm
gruppe geschickt hat zudem geht es hier
und dort bekommt ihr die videos früher
und könnte in einer ständigen gruppe
diskutieren und könnt eben
themenvorschläge macht nicht nur die
nasa und die esa sondern auch china
wollen zurück auf den mond noch in
diesem jahrzehnt sollen wieder menschen
dorthin fliegen und auch für längere
zeit dort bleiben china will unbedingt
die zweite nation nach den usa werden
die menschen auf dem mond schickt und
zwar so bald wie möglich angedacht ist
eine solche mission für die 2030er jahre
die raumfahrtstrategie chinas ist
wirklich ärgert sich und die derzeitige
mond-mission chang e 5 ist nur ein
kleiner baustein davon china hat das
große ziel eine zitat internationale
mond forschungsstation einzurichten und
china liegt gut im rennen denn bezüglich
der c5 mondmissionen wurden drei große
zwischenziele bereits jetzt erfolgreich
gemeistert die chinesische mondsonde
chang'e ii 5 war am ersten dezember 2020
auf dem mond gelandet check mittlerweile
hat sie auch rund zwei kilogramm
mondgestein eingesammelt check dann ist
es der mondsonde gelungen mit den
gesteinsproben an ihrem mutterschiff
anzudocken eine entscheidende hürde auf
dem rückweg zur erde
das unbemannte doping manöver fand in
380.000 kilometer entfernung von der
erde statt es war das erste unbemannte
doping manöver überhaupt in einer
solchen entfernung im mond orbit rund
zwei kilogramm mondgestein seien dann
sicher in der rückkehr kapsel verstaut
worden bevor sich das modul wieder löste
die chinesische raumfahrtbehörde c nsa
beschreibt das als zitat von daewoo und
andocken in der mondumlaufbahn
tatsächlich ziemlich aufregend denn nach
den bemannten mondlandungen der usa in
den 60er und 70er jahren ist es auch das
erste mal dass im mond orbit wieder ein
docking manöver gelingt das alles lässt
forschende gespannt auf die
gesteinsproben vom mond hoffen das erste
mal seit 44 jahren dass wieder gestand
proben auf dem mond gesammelt wurden und
diese dann zur erde gebracht werden
bislang ist das nur den usa und der
sowjetunion gelungen doch die mond
proben um die es jetzt geht sind jünger
und könnten somit neue und spannende
erkenntnisse über den mond liefern
doch noch kann das schiefgehen dennoch
ist die komplexe und mehr strittige
logistik nicht beendet und das rückhol
manöver zur erde steht noch aus ohne
zweifel ist jedenfalls dass diese
chinesische probe rückholaktion von
shanghai fünf äußerst anspruchsvoll ist
und bei einem fehlschlag weiter im
rennen zu sein und schnell reagieren zu
können hat china sogar einen plan b
vorbereitet die baugleiche sonde chang'e
ii 6 eine art backup fall stange fünf
scheitert falls es hier aber keinen fall
geben sollte und danach sieht es ja
bisher aus könnte shanghai 6 eingesetzt
werden um den kommenden jahren den
südpol des mondes unsicher zu machen
besetzt ist der montiert 60 einzig und
allein von aktiven gerätschaften aus
china
rang drei ist ein ende 2013 hier aktiv
und auch die gesamte channel 4 missionen
die auf der mond rückseite gelandet war
ist noch aktiv konkret ist die rede von
dem mond rover youtube 2 und dem länder
channel 4
wir hatten darüber berichtet über die
ersten pflanzen auf dem mond
baumwollsamen die dort tatsächlich
gekeimt sind gehen dann aber schnell
erfroren sind schon seit mehr als 20
jahren gibt es das chinesische programm
mit dem der mond stück für stück
erforscht werden soll
und tatsächlich lohnt sich der blick
zurück angefangen hat das mit channel 1
und channel 2
die den mond umkreiste dann gelangen
drei die weiche landung auf dem mond und
das aussetzen des rovers youtube dann
kam channel 4 und seine weiche landung
auf der rückseite des mondes im januar
des vergangenen jahres 2009 10
zudem wurde der rover youtube zwei
ausgesetzt der chinesische roboter kam
zu spektakulären erkenntnisse
denn es werden regionen des erdtrabanten
erforscht die vorher noch nie
irgend jemand zu gesicht bekommen hat
das ist übrigens nur möglich weil auch
ein satellit in die erdumlaufbahn
geschickt wurde der die daten dann
weiter zur erde sendet bereits zwei
monate nach seiner landung gab es den
ersten großen erfolg des mond roboters
an der landesstelle im sogenannten von
karmann krater weil auf eine meterdicke
sand und staub schicht gestoßen und die
es wirklich nicht ohne insgesamt zwölf
meter dick ist die schicht dessen
material er feinem sand als staub endet
die radardaten von youtube 2 machten es
dem chinesischen forschungsteam möglich
sehr detailliert unter die oberfläche
der mond rückseite zu schauen
dem forschungsteam zufolge gelang es dem
radar jana haase 2 so die deutsche
übersetzung von youtube 2 insgesamt 40
meter in die tiefe zu blicken
die analyse zeigt dass die oberste
schicht etwa zwölf meter dick ist das
fein gemahlen im regolith besteht damit
ist der feine sehr scharfkantige
mondstaub gemeint der sich sogar durch
raumanzüge fressen kann
darunter eine ebenfalls etwa zwölf meter
dicke schicht aus steinen und riesigen
felsen und in den entsprechenden
zwischenräumen dünne lagen eines feinen
materials den chinesischen beobachtungen
zufolge folgten einer region in der sich
feines und grobes material abwechseln
dabei konnten die radaraufnahmen nicht
einmal den boden des kraters nachweisen
was bedeutet dass dieser noch viel
tiefer liegen muss mit ihnen einschläge
haben nach ansicht der fachleute zu der
mindestens 40 meter dicken auflage
geführt diese habe wohl im laufe der
mond geschichte gigantische mengen an
gestein aus der mondoberfläche
geschlagen und dann verteilt doch auch
die aktuelle proben kommission chang e 5
ist nicht ohne
sie erinnert jedenfalls stark an die
bemannten apollo mission denn sie ist
nicht nur äußerst komplex sondern
beinhaltet auch eine mehrschichtige
logistik kein wunder schließlich soll
sie ja der letzte schritt china sein
bevor die nation menschen auf den mond
schickt falls die mission glück wäre es
die erste proben rückhol mission seit
1976 damals gelang das der russischen
mondsonde lunar 24 am 24 oktober 2020
war die rakete vom typ langer marsch 5
vom chinesischen weltraumbahnhof ranking
etwa anderthalb stunden nach dem start
hatte channel 5 die sonnensegel aus
gefaltet um sich so mit strom zu
versorgen
an bord die sonde die 8,2 tonnen wiegt
und aus enns
vier modulen besteht länder aufstiegs
stufe wie der eintritts kapsel und
orbiter zum einen der länder der
gemeinsam mit der aufstiegs stufe auf
dem mond gelandet ist die landung von
chf 5 spielte sich ab in der mond region
die als ozeans prozent arum bezeichnet
wird mit einem laser scanner system
hatte der länder rund 100 meter über dem
grund zur sicherheit noch einmal autonom
das landegebiet auf hindernisse
überprüft bereits kurze zeit nach der
landung hatte die chinesische raumfahrt
agentur dann berichtet dass die lande
sonne bereits ihre solarmodule aus
geklappt hatte und sich auf die
probenentnahme vorbereitet beim ozeans
prozent handelt es sich um eine bislang
unerforschte region die unter anderem
auch deswegen so spannend für die
wissenschaft ist bei diesem ca der
stürmer handelte sich um eines der
größten mond mehrere mit einem
durchmesser von 3200 kilometer
möglicherweise gab es hier noch vor ein
bis zwei milliarden jahren aktiven
vulkanismus konkret wurde der vulkanberg
monz rückkehr für die probenentnahme
ausgewählt diese region liegt im
nordwesten des mondes und die
geologischen formationen die hier zu
finden sind sind etwa 1,2 milliarden
jahre alt die mond proben die die
apollo-astronauten damals mit zur erde
brachten waren dagegen zwischen 3,1 und
4,4 milliarden jahre alt zurück zu den
modulen von 95 neben dem länder gibt es
noch die aufstieg stufe die mit dem
mondgestein in die umlaufbahn
zurückkehrt dort hat sie dann an die
wiedereintritt kapsel angedockt die
gemeinsam mit dem orbiter den mond
umkreist die wiedereintritt kapsel
wiederum soll die mond proben dann
zurück zur erde bringen und zwar in
einem speziellen behälter der noch im
dezember mit einer kapsel in der
mongolei landen soll china hatte
angekündigt dass sowohl inländische als
auch ausländische forschende die chance
bekommen sollen
die mond proben genauer ins visier zu
nehmen
chinas mond-mission chang e 5 ist also
wirklich ambitioniert und ein super
wichtiger schritt in den weltraum
programm der nation demnach möchte man
hier erfahrungen sammeln um in zukunft
auch eine bemannte landung auf dem mond
zu bringen und das zu unterstreichen
haben die chinesen wie die amerikaner
1969 eine flagge auf dem mond gehst doch
auch die nasa will zurück auf dem mond
eine bemannte nasa mission könnte sich
schon im jahr 2024 auf den weg machen
und möglicherweise eine mondstation
beziehen als erster außenposten der
menschheit auf einem anderen
himmelskörper dazu der nasa
wissenschaftler james green
geplant ist dass 2024 eine bemannte
landung auf dem mond stattfinden soll
diesmal soll aber kein mann sondern eine
astronautin zuerst aussteigen insgesamt
wird das team aus vier oder fünf
astronauten bestehen zwei oder drei auf
dem mond einer oder zwei in der umlauf
waren
dennoch für eine mondstation wie china
sie plant müssen noch so einige
herausforderungen angegangen werden denn
die umgebung auf dem erdtrabanten die
ist extrem und lebensgefährlich und
davor muss die basis ihre bewohnerinnen
und bewohnern natürlich schützen auf dem
mond ist man auch dem bombardement durch
meteoriten mehr oder weniger schutzlos
ausgeliefert hinzu kommt es gibt kein
magnetfeld keine schützende atmosphäre
und keinen sauerstoff die temperaturen
schwanken extrem bis zu 120 grad kann
sich die mondoberfläche durch die
sonneneinstrahlung auf festen in der
mond nacht und im schatten dagegen
herrschen temperaturen von minus 223
grad celsius eine unterkunft für die
zukünftigen mond bewohnerinnen und
bewohner müsste also vor diesen extremen
temperaturen schützen und das ist nur
eines von zahlreichen themen an denen
derzeit geforscht beispielsweise an
einer lunaren sauerstoff fabrik und an
baustoffen mit dem sie überhaupt ein
posten auf dem erdtrabanten errichten
ließ erste pflanzen wachsen auf dem mond
ja das ist ein video was wir über dj
vier mission gemacht haben also
anklicken anschauen und abonnieren
und zwar diesen kanal kriegs umsatz in
future bis dann bleibt dran